good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
Friday
gotta get down on strategy everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
that's right
brass and stress on strategy you tell
him sis We've Got Rice we've got stress
we've got Jacks we've got Claude and you
know what we call that
Full House yes very good very good
um yeah I brought not to make everything
about me from the second we start the
show nevertheless she persisted I
brought the stress Brothers in for my
home today and it was top five one of
the worst in outings of my life I have
heard and Jackie doesn't care your
whimperings that you're blaming Strife
sand it's 100 stress's fault
um and it's like it's kind of funny like
I'm laughing like that you don't even
really care that the three of us were
almost hit by a bus today like a big ass
MTA coach bus what happened but I know
you're gonna blame it on my boy that's
why I don't want to hear it it was his
fault what do you do we were crossing
the street we finally got here we're
crossing the street and
we're crossing in the middle of the
street jaywalking yeah
sounds like that's your I jaywalk every
single day that's the only way down with
Theo every single day and we're walking
and Bruno will like not stop walking on
my feet and I'm like tangled up in his
stupid [ __ ] leash and I tripped over
him and there was a bus coming
Abbas
to Mommy My Sweet Angel she doesn't even
care I need to come to Mommy sweet angel
like where's my love
well you had love from Bryce and strife
all week long and yeah I'm officially
giving up Bryce aside from almost
getting hit by a bus it was a great week
it was no complaints except for you know
the near-death experience which I guess
I'm not entitled to feel trauma over
rice just wanted to leave you with a
little something to remember him by oh
we remember Bryce we remember and how
was sleeping with Bryce last night you
know for me it was fine for Ben I think
it was like what will go down in history
as one of the worst night sleeps of his
life but Ben just attracts that energy
like Ben is the exact type of person you
want to sleep next to he's big and warm
and like you just want to put your face
up his ass and that's what Bruno and
Theo did all last night and how did the
boys sleep like kings and that's all
that matters 100 I tried to tell Ben I'm
like you no longer matter yeah that's
what being a parent is a stray Centric
household 100 wears hat we actually had
a great night last night because we went
out as early yeah we did oh my God that
feels like so long ago we had a gno for
Jackie's big week in town what does gdo
it was just girls dinner out
because it was at night entails like
clubs Club bus another club bus no sleep
no we had a Fab night and it was
star-studded we were out and about last
night we saw Julia Fox we saw Jeff Ross
we saw Nikki Hilton my girl my girly
girl
um it was pop in New York was on fire
yeah we were at a cool place we were
being cool so like when you're as cool
as us like cool things just like happen
around you because you're cool you know
only person I was missing who are The
Strife Brothers but they were at home
waiting for me when I got home I enjoyed
my last night with Bryce I am ready to
give him back to you okay but that
doesn't mean I don't love it and enjoy
every minute he spent with me no I'm so
glad I know he made much Headway on his
Memoirs and he was so grateful for
everyone who weighed in yesterday in the
comments letting him know what he should
title his book honestly I didn't find
that there was a consensus though like
people were really split and there's a
third option now that I'm very is very
compelling lucky is streis alive
that's it that's the one but we did get
Theo's Memoir title pup with no job the
crazy beautiful life of an Instagram
thirst monster no of a Strife brother
sure
which leads me to my book available at
Amazon Barnes Noble and anywhere you get
any type of book ebook audiobook you
want to hear my stunning voice because
you love this podcast so much it's a New
York Times best-selling Memoir um it's
spent about uh 30 seconds on the charts
but it got there and it counts and
honestly people loved it like I loved it
but people like said it was like the
best like kind of like Da Vinci Code
Vibes yeah no that was like I was so
confused when I was reading one because
I was like right is it Da Vinci Code or
and people are talking about Tom Hanks
potentially starring in the adaptation
of the of the book and he'll be playing
girl
um did Bryce get any tips for me on how
to write your Memoirs while he was
staying with you he was kind of like too
proud to ask
her he was talking to me about it all
week saying I'm gonna ask her we're
gonna do a workshop she didn't even
mention it not the workshop
um he left a workshop we have like
like a crazy couple of you know like
it's just a next week will just be a big
week I'm just trying not to be annoying
just know like this is the last episode
of the morning toast where we're just
regular girls no this is the last
episode of the morning toast like as you
know it right now yeah there will be
some change starting on Monday all great
nothing crazy show will be every day
we're not going anywhere blah blah blah
but just like some changes set a little
bit of a
a shift a shifting stressack I don't
wanna I don't want to give anything away
and you might think you could guess it
but when I tell you you're wrong but I
would love to see you try sure sure I'm
sure someone would guess it if like no
try as they may no I don't think so
so nothing like so so just remember
these faces
and things are gonna just be different
starting Monday yeah and I love a secret
project and it's only like a three day
tease you guys can handle it yeah but
just know like
it's enormous like it's so big pretty
big it's pretty big
um and we've got a great show we both
watched
the new episode of the Kardashians on
hula which we will do in the TV recap I
also watched this morning
um real house has a Salt Lake City and
my God I just I can't you know yeah
there was nothing that I didn't mention
it's just can you forgive Lisa Barlow no
that's the question and the fact that
that's the question is beyond me because
we have a woman on on a major trial and
we didn't even talk about it yeah so
that's for me that's why I can't
personally okay
that's just a little bit about me
I'm understanding also we are just like
churning out content yesterday
we had a new podcast up on the patreon
um that's been requested for a while and
I wanted to make sure the person I
recorded it with was like comfortable
enough to like you know like in his own
life to then share because you know not
everyone just like once again on a
podcast and like spill their guts yeah
or fill their guts
um so one of my best friends who I talk
about all the time Abe that I feel like
if you listen to the toast you always
hear me talking about him he's the one
who does oh Robert did he do it of
course
um I sat down with him for like an
hour-long interview just like talking
about like who is Abe
um our friendship over I've known him
for like 15 years and he like recently
went through like a major life change
and I feel like people
um
might be able to relate to so it was
really good it was really fun it was
like so weird to podcast with like a
friend you have to like go into like
work mode boys no he was like you're
being so weird no I was giving Claudia
no and like you're usually like the one
on the toes who like steers us along and
like it's professional and I just like
sit here and like burp
um so it was like unnatural for me to be
that person and then also in front of
someone I like know deeply personally
like it was just weird it is weird and
then we have another patreon episode
coming up today today my New York City
Vlog I've been vlogging my whole week so
you'll get the behind the scenes and all
the stuff that we're doing and like a
lot of the secret projects project
teasers and it's just been a jam-packed
week so I've been so good about vlogging
like everything that I'm doing and it's
it's a great Vlog I it will be up today
um because that's a wrap on my like work
week right and I actually was supposed
to go home today but instead I'm going
home Sunday because my flight was
canceled right we actually weren't even
supposed to have a show today because
Jackie was headed back with her fam to
Florida but obviously the hurricane yeah
canceled my flight so I will be here
through the weekend so we're just gonna
be hanging and slaying and slanging and
hanging and banging banging me and Bryce
and Strikes oh yeah just like your book
that you were telling us about in the
car last night
oh my God that is the last time I take a
recommendation from Tick Tock I was led
astray I was led astray I went a little
too far into the porn the porn yeah and
I guess like I didn't realize like the
books that I like is porn like aren't
that crazy because you read a crazy one
and they were like if you like It
Happened One Summer try this
I can't I can't I can't I actually
removed it from my shelf like that's how
like not okay I was she spiced too close
to the sun no I took it too far like I
took it too far and I learned my lesson
do you want to tell us what it was
called or no like I'm I'm genuinely
embarrassed to be associated with this
book
and like if you read it like I don't
want to call you out you know like right
right like what if you liked it and I'm
over here saying it's disgusting I'm
Kink shaming right not the king shaming
um
so I feel like I'm ready to dive in
today's really exciting because we have
a A og sponsor that's made a return
and people are gonna Quake because this
was I feel like a sponsor that like
really had to send a show called yeah me
in particular right it's not sent bird
which is so sad no is Stanford still in
business like I think so just like not
with us maybe like our work here was
done I feel like everyone got their
scent first sometimes that's what
happens like right you go so hard for a
brand like everyone who listens to the
podcast yeah that's true
so I guess without further Ado where are
you right here sitting comfortably with
your mom and yet Andy it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
rothies for versatile shoes that are
stylish and still feel comfortable shop
rothies their signature seamless knit
design looks and feels great right out
of the box with no break-in period plus
transitioning to a new fall look is easy
with rothy's shoes so many colors that
work season after season it is a
no-brainer to wear a pair honestly the
no-brainer comes from a lot of different
facets but I would say the number one
facet like the number one selling point
for Roth is that you can throw them in
the washing machine yeah their wash
ability is crazy you can wash them after
every wash like if you are prone to
smelly feet which you know what some of
us are okay and there's no shame in it
especially with rothies because like
sometimes you don't want to wear a sock
with rothies you don't have to because
they're so comfortable but like you
could ruin a pair of shoes not wearing
socks one time because your feet are so
smelly it could happen and I'm not
speaking from experience I swear I'm not
it's Ben no it's like it's not it's not
me I swear like I I didn't have to put
powder in my shoes growing up like I
didn't like that's maybe no no
um that's why rothies is really like a
fabulous brand that we love we've
supported and worn for a long time they
haven't been sponsoring our show for a
little while so now we've got a code and
I really want I really want everyone to
get in on this because it's a really
special moment I know they weren't
sponsoring the show for a while it
didn't change things no my love for Roth
I hold no resentment I have two pairs of
rothies and I should put them in the
washing machine thanks for the reminder
because they are worn to the ground and
you've had them for a while they're
really durable like over a year no I
remember we were reading for them in
2019 the best year on record right and
maybe it was because of raw things I was
going I was like flying all over the
place brought these on the plane there's
no better shoe swollen feet rothies from
the hospital when I gave birth because I
got a big foot
that's nice yeah so if you want stylish
shoes that are versatile and durable
enough to wear all the time go to
rothies and if you want 20 off your
first purchase at rothies go to
rothies.com EMT rothies is spelled
r-o-t-h-y-s by the way I'm like quaking
right now do you know that the word
rothies has all the same letters ex of
ashrae except for tea I think o s h r y
it's the same letters except there's
also a t so tashray
I thought you were gonna say rothies it
sounds like ruthies it does which is why
I think we have like a particular
affinity for the brand
r-o-t-h-y-s.com slash TMT today's
episode is also brought to you by studs
you guys are probably noticing the
ultimate cool girl look is a fully
loaded and stacked ear and it's a little
intimidating but not if you check out
studs they are they've coined the term
earscape and they are the go-to
Authority for piercings and earrings
excuse me for what
there they go to Authority for what I
must issue a correction and issue I'm
doing I'm going to do better they are
the go-to Authority for parsings and
earrings and they can help you curate an
earscape that's based on your own
anatomy and style so they are
reimagining the piercings
they are reimagining the parsing
experience for each and every ear if you
want to refresh your look with a new
parsing or you need a professional
styling advice you can shop online or
shop at studs in La New York City Austin
Nashville Miami Boston Seattle and they
have more coming soon if you want to get
uh first if you're a first time parser
you want to have a parsing party check
out studs it can be a little
intimidating and I feel like there's no
place to really go back in the day like
there was Claire's but there's no like
OG Place anymore for piercings and studs
has become that I feel like if you want
to get a piercing now you go to like a
tattoo shop and it's just not like a
warm and friendly environment you know
yeah yeah and like it's like you want to
have a selection of earrings to choose
from and you just want to be among
fellow parsers and they do it like
really safe and clean they use
single-use needles they don't use guns
it's way safer way better especially if
you're doing an advanced piercing
um and then their earrings are just
fabulous they're made from high quality
materials they will not turn your skin
green they're lightweight and durable
enough to wear all the time whenever I
do a read for
um studs you know what I think of what
please like just when I got my ears no
no it's it's not like a personal thing
it's like um a reference from a film
like how like you can walk out of studs
with like a fresh piercing and like
sickening new earrings not like those
gold balls
what's gold balls country's strong when
she's like complaining that she I'll get
the boring gold balls late in maester
and then he buys her the ones that she
wanted she needed to go to studs her
number's on they have over 250 styles of
Hoops Huggies studs cuffs dangles they
pierce way more than just your earlobes
and it's easy to create a statement look
or something to keep every day starting
at just ten dollars a piercing right now
studs is offering our listeners 20 off
your first purchase when you go to
studs.com toast
I have a ton of earrings from studs I
love their Hoops I'm like a dainty
earring girl
um and studs is the place for me studs
is studs.com toast for 20 20 off your
first purchase studs.com slash toast
studs that's where we got our ears
parsed well said couldn't put a bed of
myself actually yeah no there's no
better slogan than that
our first story is just a story that
warmed my heart this morning and a way
for me to talk about the Royals in a
celebrity manner coupled with Miles
Teller okay how Miles Teller broke Royal
protocol when meeting Prince William and
Kate Middleton when at the premiere of
Top Gun in London Miles Teller
referenced the moment he broke Royal
protocol while meeting the new Prince
and Princess of Wales he was on The
Tonight Show starring Jimmy Fallon and
said right off the bat I messed up
you're not supposed to extend your right
your hand right off the bat unless they
do but I felt the vibe so I'm like I'm
going in I'm going in he shared that he
was given the rules of do's and don'ts
that he wouldn't [ __ ] up while meeting
William and Kate but he admitted that
etiquette went out the window because he
was Charmed by the newly named Prince
and Princess of Wales I can understand
that he said quote to their credit they
were very disarming I was lost Prince
William's eyes he described them as the
blue as The Bluest ocean he said Kate
was beautiful and cordial and holds
herself so well in Regal and with
William I'm calling another woman
beautiful I'm with William I don't know
I just blacked out he said his greeting
was such a disaster that his cast mate
Jennifer Connolly was seen laughing as
the events unfolded he said I was kind
of riffing on what this interaction was
going to be like so I think she was
already on alert about if she thought I
was going to go a bit Rogue about the
whole thing so he's like a royalist like
how he stands
um I think that like William K probably
didn't think anything of it I'm sure
people are always like quaking in front
of them yeah but I'm sure they get a
charge out of it especially when it's a
movie star like Miles Teller I'm sure
they're big fans of his I'm sure they
loved Kate was like
like hey hey boy
she's in love with the boy perhaps I
mean maybe but I feel like there was
just Mutual adoration all around which
makes it all kosher I love when the
Royals go to movie premieres it's very
rare it's so fast it's only for like big
Studio like moments and it's fabulous
so fabulous and I I love this friendship
for them and I love that Miles Teller
respects the hell out of the royal
family I also love that Miles teller's
Miles Teller is in the Press obviously
he's in New York right now he's on SNL
tomorrow I will be watching yes um who's
the musical guest
such a good question it's a really good
question it's like depending on who the
either musical guest or host is
sometimes someone people get eclipsed
like
remember when Adele was
on and she didn't she wasn't the musical
performer it was her
her yes and like it actually felt bad
for her
Yes except then that iconic ladies and
gentlemen
he's performing with Kendrick Lamar so
stunning that'll be a great Duo I'm
actually excited for SNL like I
uh it's a type of thing where I'm not
gonna watch every episode it just really
depends on the host and I think Miles
was a great choice what is promoting
right now
promoting like top gun's over Maybe Just
Smiles you know it's about time actually
promoting his new Memoir miles to go by
Miley Cyrus oh that's good that was the
name of hers okay when she was 15 and
she wrote A Memoir oh I I and I read it
I need more Memoirs for underdeveloped
like yeah no but like when you're a kid
you're a fan of someone they get a book
deal and I'll read it sure yeah what
have we been up to the last 15 years I
do feel like now would be a good time
just to have like a small very peaceful
intervention with you about choices
memoirs about the Royals like you need
to stop like you need to stop you need
to stop like when there's something to
talk about like let's talk about it
yesterday's story honestly I didn't know
about and once we discussed I was okay
this is a little silly but it's miles no
and even though
[Music]
I would take a bullet for him but like
Oh I wanna do
is speak about no Queen Elizabeth too no
Jackie even if we're miles miles apart
All I Wanna Do
is speak my truth speak my truth I liked
mine because I was just trying to tell
you that I want to talk about Queen
Elizabeth you know I'm like I get it but
like it's we're getting to the point
where like even I'm getting fatigued you
know imagine how I feel that's darks
armed run into the mountain the thing is
you can't really compare
um oh by the way and it's a Friday like
it's not like I'm
missing major news about the Royals grab
your list okay by the way we had so much
to add to the stories that I don't stop
repeating okay we have to add tarek's
armed run into the woods his arms hike
like not wrong charics arm tiger Musa
yeah I talk about that all the time
because honestly nobody else does yeah
also my list of regrets Taylor schrecker
not being at my wedding oh okay wait I
need to merge these lists I should just
have like one yeah it should be on one
note yep I'm on it
thank you to everyone who contributed
yesterday in the comment section to
things I repeat it's nice to know how
you all really feel about me no it's
nice to know they're listening that's
true that's definitely firstly Taylor
strecker not at claude's wedding that's
definitely a regret of mine yeah that's
bad like that's crazy considering she's
your best friend now yeah no it's like
Beyond that's what you get for getting
married at 17. I know like honestly
15. it wasn't it wasn't the vibe like
you know I really do wish I waited but
what I should date someone for 18 years
listening to meet Taylor strecker and
invite her to your wedding eventually
maybe if I hadn't gotten married my life
would have take you know a butterfly
flaps its wings yeah so there's no way
no you you're and that's no shade to Ben
it is no you you did what you should
have done it's just sad for Taylor
schrecker yeah I feel like she's always
getting the shafted like she's always
getting the [ __ ] end yeah okay any other
repeated stories that people were
commenting that we should add to the
list let me just triple check but really
the one that stood out to me was Tariq
almost I do bring it up a lot because
first of all we're always talking about
them because they're always updating in
their love rhombus of course and um
nobody else like remembers and I just
feel like it's important because I think
like him being really scary and weird
it's definitely a part of the drama and
it's also like a part of Christina's
story right repeated story is
oh I guess when like the thing that
started on burning your cells like when
I fell
but I feel like I actually don't talk
about that a lot yeah no I don't think
you like tell the story a lot
um okay here somebody wrote when I went
on the boat with Leo I feel like because
for how cool that is I actually don't
talk about it as much as I could I agree
the notovirus
but you know what you experience it and
try not talking about it okay not me
getting defensive like when people are
just trying to help Dennis's funeral
obviously
um
okay I think that's a like we can only
Circle back yeah now that we have these
lists oh and like things I repeat it's
not a story but saying I would take a
bullet like just oh yeah yeah those are
one of my favorite phrases you guys
hella bullets okay so you're not gonna
like our next story either but I do
think it's worth talking about oh my God
it's Friday like let me have something
in town like it's what a day Prince
George no no seriously enough enough
I've had enough because you're making me
hate these people warrant his Pals my
dad will be king so you better watch out
okay you know what if you had to choose
one Royal story like this would have
been it but now we've all and now we've
said it but you don't want to talk about
miles and miles and miles you could just
talk about how miles is on us and all
this weekend like we're so excited what
do we think he's going to talk about you
know is he gonna bring Kelly up for a
skit do you think so I hope so now that
she's an actress she stars in Taylor
Swift videos right she's the real actor
Maybe Taylor will come to the after
party oh for sure see there's so much we
could talk about even I don't think
Taylor's in New York
where would she be
um I feel like she like lives in London
but I'm not entirely sure she's so
mysterious and I appreciate that if you
let me have this story I will I'll put a
royal filter on my sections going
forward no like it's honestly and truly
it's enough like we don't need one a day
we don't even live there
I just feel I just think you have really
comfortable when it was like the queen
passed and like every story was that and
I know you're trying to recreate the
magic I understand I've been there with
the Suez it's yeah it's very smooth
okay but this is funny so can we please
just talk about it and then you can like
stop being mean to me and we can move on
I'm really not being mean I'm not but
like we like like it's become
insufferable but like it's Friday
whatever you keep saying that like as it
is some sort of Royal right I think
there's no stories like it's not like
it's a Monday and I'm forsaking the
juice to talk about Prince George you're
forsaking the juice the juice the juicy
stories right to talk about Prince
George threatening his classmates okay
go for it sure like Prince George is
showing the world who's boss the
nine-year-old Royal reportedly made sure
his Chums at school knew who he was
according to a new book Katie Nichols
new book the new Royals Queen
Elizabeth's Legacy and the future of the
crown gotta pick it up out October 4th
alleges that the eldest son of Prince
William and Kate told his peers that
they had better watch out reiterating
that the Prince of Wales will be king
one day the author writes George
understands he will one day be king and
as a little boy uh Bart he sparred with
friends at school out doing his peers
with the killer line my dad will be king
so you better watch out he's not not
wrong like his dad will be king so you
should watch out like immediately sent
to the tower treason who's going to the
tower today kids by the way one story
that we should talk about because I feel
like we spoke about it yesterday like
just on a personal level
um is there's like drama with the new
Jeffrey Dahmer Netflix thing
the victims of Jeffrey Dahmer's their
families are like enough
yeah I haven't seen anything other than
I was perusing Netflix and I I hovered
over Jeffrey Dahmer I wasn't ever going
to watch it that's not my beat me
neither
um and I saw like a little clip and it
was like
like Jeffrey looks like a sexy like
Punchy music quirky like ooh come into
my room locked door and it's like
it's a little too positive it's like a
little too light and bright no and just
when I read that headline where it was
like the victims of Jeffrey Dahmer's
families are like asking Netflix to
please stop like we we keep being
re-traumatized it kind of put back into
perspective like Jeffrey Dahmer is not a
fictional character like he was a real
ass person who like murdered real ass
women yeah and it's like why like I feel
like crime culture has gotten like a
little out of control I agree and I also
saw a headline that originally the
um you know how like when you have a
show on Netflix it could be in like the
romance category yeah it was in lgbtq
cat like why I I don't know maybe he was
gay I don't know a lot about him I just
feel like that's like a little
homophobic like I took it off good with
that
category that title off I think they
should take down the show okay I've not
seen it I haven't heard that's really
[ __ ] weird like lgbtq like
um
I mean I don't think they meant anything
really nefarious but it's like what are
I don't know I don't know which every
dimmer story so I don't know
well no that you can have multiple it's
not the only it's weird it's weird even
though maybe the show so that you add as
many like subjects on it so yeah as much
as you can and they don't people didn't
like that I just feel like between all
the podcasts all the documentaries and
I've watched a few and I feel like the
ones that I've watched like were really
crazy stories that like needed to be
told like I always think of that one
that we both watched
American killer next door or something
yeah where Chris whatever killed his
wife and kids and like threw them in a
water tank like just a horrible story
horrible
um and I didn't like get enjoyment from
that I feel like people like well
there's a difference between a
documentary and a [ __ ] and a fictional
that's so true by the way I just think
we've gotten to a place where like it's
enough and it's really [ __ ] weird
yeah and that's why I feel like just
like about a lot of the podcast too even
the last time we spoke about crime
podcasts like I got a lot of feedback
that a lot of the big crime shows like
do amazing work with the families and
they raise money the crime junkies does
a lot
um
but it's weird but it seems like this
show and I don't know enough and that's
like morbid right is that the one that's
in the comedy yeah section of the
podcast like why
what's funny yeah but I haven't listened
to it so I can't say yeah I haven't
looked into the show enough but I just I
finished my movie and then the preview
for Jeffrey Dahmer show came up and I
was like this is [ __ ] twisted and
nasty like tacky are you like making it
so fun glamorous it's a cute choice so
it felt like Ryan Murphy right right
like like literally
um scream Queens yeah it felt like
scream Queens but like this is a real
story yeah with like real victims it's
really weird yeah and I just think like
the cultures I got like we've taken it
too far officially it's one thing to be
like intrigued and like want to
investigate and like be kind of like
obsessed with crime it's another one
it's like so entertaining to the point
where like you forget that this is like
a real thing that happened yeah I just
think it's weird yeah so I think you
should listen to the videos and they
should have been consulted in the first
place agreed and the show should come
down honestly it's causing more trouble
than it's worth I come sorry maybe you
should do sleep over the sequel and you
won't get in trouble oh Evan Peters is
Jeffrey Dahmer he's like so like not
famous do you know what I mean like
yeah he's like kind of like what Shia
LaBeouf I feel like could have been he's
like I've never seen a Paparazzi picture
of him yeah I've never like heard about
him like he dated Emma Roberts right a
little bit but like other than that I
don't know much about his personal life
he must have like a nice work-life
balance yeah did you see Kelly Clarkson
on the cover I think it was like
Hollywood Reporter variety something
it's all coming up Kelly and she was
like not to brag but like I am like I
always hear other people who are like On
My Level being like it's so tough like I
can't go to the grocery store like
people recognize me she's like I go to
Target um every day and like nobody
cares like she's like I have the best
life like she acknowledged it like she
has all the fame and all the rich and
all the money but she literally leads
the most normal life like nobody cares
when she goes to the supermarket and
that's what she deserves 100 peace she
has new music coming out next year and
it's been so long yeah since we were six
from our girly
the last album was like Love So Soft
yeah not my favorite but Kelly can do no
wrong 100 not complaining 100 and I look
forward to seeing what she's bringing to
the table creatively creatively
because I'm like I don't have the time
to do like new music Friday new releases
fine every single person single but like
when one of my faves drops an album I'll
be showing up for them yes I agree I'll
be playing it on repeat counselor is
always keeping up like oh did you hear
the new signal from blank that used to
be me it's a lot of work yeah no but
like I listen to albums at a time and
put it on the Sonos like I'm not just
listening to like one-off songs I agree
unless I'm working out and then I'm just
listening to 10 Things I Hate About You
on repeat thinking of Madison Lacroix
my favorite girl yikes okay are you
ready for our next story yes
Met Gala 2023 theme has been revealed
and it's a gorgeous theme it's a tribute
to the late Carl Lagerfeld Vogue
revealed on Friday that the 2023
mechelle theme will pay tribute to the
late Carl Lagerfeld nearly four years
after his death from pancreatic cancer
at the age of 85. the exhibition called
Carl Lagerfeld a line of beauty will
explore the illustrious designer's
career which spanned from 1954 to 2019
across multiple High fashion brands
including Balman Chloe Fendi Chanel and
his own eponymous line in addition to
being heavily involved in the 2015
Chanel themed event Lagerfeld was a
fixture at the Met Gala over the years
as he was close friends with Anna and
one of the industry's most lauded names
that's a really good theme like amazing
I think there's a lot that you could do
with it and I'm really looking forward
I'm really looking forward the bar is
high because Carl is watching and
everybody should be dressing Through The
Eyes of Carl and if done correctly
everyone should look amazing and I'm
looking forward to that also the exhibit
sounds amazing while you're here it
probably doesn't start yet but whenever
it's up I would love to go yeah I feel
like um there's a lot of different like
routes you can take but overall it's
going to be like full on glamor and the
thing is with the last couple of
um mechala themes it's like they require
an explanation if you're not like an art
history and fashion double major which
I'm not and it's just like not fun to
participate when like you feel stupid
and I think this is like a little bit
easier to digest while also being like a
really good theme yeah and the themes
have gotten so big and almost vague like
come to Garson oh you love that's a
little too specific come into Garcon
like what did that mean but this I feel
like is very specific Carl has had so
many eras there's so much that you can
pull from not everyone will be looking
the exact same but Carl doesn't flop so
I shouldn't see one floppy look on the
red Carpenter they shouldn't be allowed
to do a door no you're 100 right and I
think that this is a great theme and I
agree it'll be a great exhibit and I'm
excited I really am it's reinvigorating
my excitement for the Met Gala things
got like really off the wagon yeah
between covid and and the last theme
that they did twice that everyone stunk
up the joints at and in hindsight like
it was just bad I think we're getting
back to the roots here this is real
fashion I have I loved Heavenly Bodies I
thought that was an amazing theme that
was like so many years ago at this point
and I really liked camp like I didn't
like I didn't appreciate it at the time
and now that like I'm really into drag
culture like so much of drag culture is
camping like I get it more and I wish I
could have appreciated at the time
because now I look back and I'm like
that's so Camp yeah and I'm looking Camp
right in the eye oh are you ever
constantly and you've got to keep the
other eye out for Selena right I'm in
perpetuity my eyes are one for Selena
looking Camp right in the eye on the
other that's why I'm always wonky-eyed
anyways so excited yeah that's a good
one I wonder I was watching Kardashians
last night was like February and I just
happened to be thinking about like Kim
and her Marilyn dress and like I wonder
when people like Kim who it's like their
whole
year when they start thinking about
their look for the Met Gala
um she's probably already at this time
because it's February and Miguel was in
May she probably already has but like
um it's probably still like conceptual I
don't think she I wonder if who she's
going with I wonder who like the big
designer for this will be considering he
worked at all those places right she
probably go with Fendi maybe because
Fendi skin I'm wearing Sandy skins today
are you and I'm wearing good American
look at us oh my God queens and I
like I do really miss like the time when
the Kardashians were like balm on
girlies like them and Olivier and like
those iconic structured mini dresses and
the Blazers that was an iconic time and
I feel like just like fashion has moved
on from that like Luke but I wouldn't
mind a a Bowman moment with them too I
hope the whole family goes together
that's what I would love to see in my
heart of hearts like everyone was at the
same table dressed
yeah and giving us a moment that's what
we need now you know I do think like we
could have gotten that if Kim and Kanye
had stayed married because like I could
see Yeezy becoming like an official
designer of the Met Gala and remember
how he dressed them all including
Caitlyn for um the life of Pablo and
Lamar no that was very easy oh they all
look so good at his like album release
thing and it was really iconic yeah
that's what we need that is what we need
like that's really I know for other
people like they're looking to the Met
Gala for other stars but a lot of people
like it's now the Kardashian but I feel
like even when you're in there that's
what like a lot of the Articles say it's
like they're the popular girls like Demi
Lovato said that when she had the worst
time of the Mac Alice she was like
there's like a popular table no but I
feel like they're not if they're the
popular girls that they're like kind
with their popularity yeah I don't think
that they're mean yeah I feel like it's
their party now but you know what
Cara Delevingne is definitely gonna be
like the belle of the ball this year
because she was like Carl's Muse yeah
and she's still doing his line right
loves Carl so is Kai Gerber was one of
Carl's girlies like I just associate
like if there's one Muse it's Cara yeah
I agree and I saw a um was I hosting
with Shannon or with you when we were
talking about like those photos that
came out of Cara Delevingne like looking
a little we talked a little bit about it
but it wasn't a story
um she went out there was like a big
party for Cara X Carl and she looked
really good like she looked much better
and I hope that she can
keep that keep up that energy because we
need her for the Met Gala we really do
yeah she's the one to watch she's the
one to watch for sure you gotta keep an
eye at first Cara yeah but I am
constantly keeping an eye out for
something she's also one to watch at the
Met Gala she always shows up and shows
out with coach and yeah Tiffany's and I
feel like she did like Stella McCartney
for a while yeah
she's a good girl good girl are you
ready for our next story I Am David
Beckham confronted Brooklyn about Nicola
Peltz drama look talking about this
gives me such a pit like this is so
personal like so real though I know and
like it was so how was all this getting
out like for real like how do we know if
this is Trail for all okay David Beckham
reportedly confronted Brooklyn Beckham
over the drama involving
um Brooklyn's wife Nicola and his mom
Victoria quote I don't think David has
ever lost September with Brooklyn or had
cause to talk to him harshly but that
has now finally happened to source told
the Daily Mail like your dad yelling at
you is on The Daily Mail like that's so
invasive he said that the athlete read
the riot act to his eldest child quote
he had it out with him and told him we
don't do this in our family and you know
that we don't do this in our family they
added that David allegedly told Brooklyn
what happens next is up to you but we
are done with the drama per the
publication David was upset over
comments made by Nicola and Brooklyn in
the recent interview for grazia USS fall
2022 cover the young couple spoke about
the media coverage of Nicholas
relationship with Victoria she said
quote he said quote to be honest my wife
is obviously my first priority and I
never want to see her upset ever when
people do say ridiculous things we just
talk about it and we just move on we
have each other's back 100 and we just
move on so they did talk about it I
think they thought that they were
sounding respectful and on its face it
is but I think the fact that they talked
about it is disrespectful and it
validated all of these reports that and
if they didn't mention it we could all
still pretend like oh it's the media
Conjuring no that's so true and I just
feel like they're not that type of
family like they don't thirst out and
like air their dirty laundry and I think
I think they did it because
even though like Victoria is ice queen I
think the general narrative was like
Nicola is like a diva and a mean girl so
she went on the offensive to kind of
right that wrong but I feel like that
actually wasn't really The Narrative I
feel like there's that with that people
say that you know there are some like
Dumas stuff obviously the Bella Thorn
bullying thing like there are some
people who are like oh Nicholas a mean
girl but I don't feel like that's the
overarching narrative I actually feel
like the fact that she felt the need to
defend herself is more so because like
that's it's like she's projecting do you
know what I mean like you're like we're
fine yeah I feel like there's
if they if they never spoke about it you
could just say oh they're both icy and
they're just like not seeing eye to eye
right and we have no proof that this is
actually true but her making a
declaration validates everything that's
the the most important Point
um
and I'm glad that his daddy me too I'm
glad for it because even though I agree
with the sentiment like that you know
your wife comes before your
mother-in-law but you would all publicly
is beyond inappropriate David and
Victoria are both a-listers their whole
family has been celebrity famous for how
many years and they've never found
themselves in a situation like this like
right what's the new variable no and
Brooklyn like being out out here being
married to Nicola being wanting to be a
chef after literally making a grilled
cheese one time
um all of that is because he's David and
Victoria's son like and I'm sure it
feels like a huge slap in the face to
like give your kid this life just for
him to like run off and like talk about
you in the Press even if it is wasn't
like outwardly negative no and it's the
it's the mentioning it in the Press but
also whatever's happening in private
like yeah clearly choosing his wife over
his family and there shouldn't have to
be a choice yes I agree even though like
if there ever is a choice like I'm of
the mind that like you go with yourself
did something terrible happen right like
what what is so bad that they can't come
back from yeah that she didn't make the
dress right get over it yeah
but no I would feel upset too if like
someone was talking about something in
the family to the Press without like
clearing it with me first because like
family things stay family yeah and
anything that's happened in private like
we can all move on from but once it's
out there you can put it back in people
will always like
I'm glad that he got a talking to him I
agree I hope the two of them can change
their tune and just stop it I agree and
just go be happy together and then
figure out the family stuff in time yeah
they just need like a little break yeah
but David is right I'm sure that wedding
was like
a torture Fest for everyone I mean think
of think of everyone's weddings and it's
not that you know and everyone at their
own weddings whatever how big or how
small is tortured the in-laws but then
you add the scale of how much money they
have in the paparazzi and the fame and
the tablets it must have been like the
most harrowing experience so they need a
little time to debrief from wedding
drama totally without like we should be
fine until you start putting stuff in
the press that you can't take that back
totally
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is a little exciting content
news
Community the movie is finally happening
at peacock fulfilling the show's
prophecy wait what's Community Joe
McHale the teacher Community College
yeah the greatest show ever that has a
million lives and everyone keeps
canceling it and picking it up and
canceling it again but now maybe it's
not the Darkest Timeline after all is
six seasons and a movie is finally
becoming reality peacock has ordered a
movie based on The Dan Harmon comedy
community bringing back original Stars
Joel McHale Danny PewDie Allison Brie
Jillian Jacobs Jim Rash Ken Jeong to
check in on what the gang from Greendale
has been up to since the show ended in
2015. cute without sharing specifics
peacock and Sony Pictures TV which
jointly announced the green light on
Friday describe the negotiations for
peacock to secure the movie as heavily
competitive as part of the dlpcock has
also acquired non-exclusive rights to
the full six season Community Library
which can also be found on Netflix and
Hulu that would be a great show to
re-watch yeah I watched like the first
two episodes and I like never got into
it but I didn't really give it like the
of the full I didn't give it my full
energy oh I watched it when it was on
back in the day and I loved it yeah I
feel like it's really like a niche
audience it is but they're so
enthusiastic and that's why this show
like refuses to die you're small But
Mighty we're small But Mighty it's
literally been 15 years and now they're
getting a movie that's nice maybe I will
watch it it's the funniest premise for a
show and the cast so what's the premise
again they all go to Community College
yeah but they all have like a different
reasons for how they ended up there and
obviously they're not College age oh got
it okay I think like maybe maybe Alison
Brie's character was and like she this
is where she got in or something got it
that's funny it's so funny okay that is
a good show I get that confused honestly
I know it sounds crazy with like Parks
and Rec no they're all pretty similar
they're all like 30 minute sitcoms that
are funny from NBC and people got so
famous from them and people really love
them and feel strongly about them but
you can't like have watched all of them
no and I did start Parks and Rec and
like it was not funny and that is a fact
of life it's not my opinion it's a sheer
fact I didn't watch Works in wreck I
didn't watch most of that but it's weird
that I did watch Community because oh
it's not weird because I love Joel
McHale and I loved the soup when it was
on and I would have followed him till
the ends of the Earth the soup was a
really unique time in my life
it was a good time it was so it was such
a like it was I don't even know what I
would call it because it was like late
night but it was a variety show and it
had like little segments it was
literally like The Amanda Show you know
what I would call it what so meaty chat
still right that's what I would call it
yeah I didn't even like understand half
the things they were saying no but I was
cracking up and then we were literally
12. I didn't eat like promise to bring
it back they brought it back with a
female host yes
and now because everything he touches
turns to trash like it just like
shrivels up yeah and dies and like
becomes embarrassing like I don't think
people have looked at Busy Phillips the
same oh yeah
yeah when she was like prancing around
in an eye gown and big hoop earrings
like Fred Rogers it was Mr Rogers it was
a lot it was a lot
um
that's what you missed on good that's
what you missed we know you needed to
know every morsel of that
most morsels every last one right
straight sends you'll support your mommy
we have TV recap the Kardashians episode
on Hulu episode 2 of season two was
released on Wednesday night and we
caught up with the girlies and we're
gonna recap it it is brought to you by
Bruce the electric toothbrush
that will change the way you think about
brushing your teeth with powerful Sonic
technology and Ultra Gentle bristles the
brush redefines what it means to have
super clean teeth it's like that feeling
when you just leave the dentist a fresh
whole clean mouth every single day and
if you want to get 20 off when you pick
your brush brush kit and plan you can go
to brush.com toast for 20 off at
bruush.com toast so the brush kit
includes the electric toothbrush an
additional three brush heads a magnetic
charging station and a very Sleek very
slender very portable travel case the
subscription plan
um comes every six months they'll ship
you a three pack replacement brush head
to your door it's way better for the
environment than replacing your entire
toothbrush and you got to change your
brush head it's like kind of gross if
you don't changing your brush head is
really easy to forget so they'll just
remind you with a little message
for 18 US dollars or 24 Canadian dollars
it's pretty good given gas mileage right
now you want to drive to the pharmacy
and get a new one they also have a great
90-day return policy because they
believe in the product so wholeheartedly
they're going to give you a 90-day trial
to test and try the product and you can
rest assured because based on thousands
of five-star reviews you will not be
returning this brush comes in stunning
colors I have a hunter green a magenta a
pale pink you could say I have a problem
do I need three electric toothbrushes no
um but it really is that [ __ ] and it's
super affordable compared to other
um electric toothbrushes they can cost
like 200 which is a lot like it's out of
control so uh super affordable and when
you use our link 20 off at the Bruce
brush kit and plan when you go to
bruce.com toast
bruush.com toast
when you just like literally like
waiting like was it bursting out of you
while I was doing that yeah and I'm
staring at boot to do and he's like what
are you calling for me are you calling
for your toothbrush mom
um so episode two we got Kylie's birth
which was stunning it was very emo I
mean I I enjoyed it but I didn't really
relate to like the conversation
afterwards about like you know how
different it is the second time and just
being hard on your body yada yada but I
imagine that like it made you feel seen
it made me feel seen she's my queen
right now yeah everything that comes out
of her mouth I could just sit there and
watch her talk slowly about anything
like I wish every scene with her is just
so precious to me
um and a lot of what she was saying I
really really appreciate it I feel like
she's been so open about what she's gone
through even when she was talking about
how she's been home since November just
like hanging out with a four-year-old
and then I guess she went to Coachella
Justin Bieber Kelly took her remember in
April so she was really like home and
that's really what I experienced yeah
and I just love her so dearly it's
definitely resurfacing that like I want
to know the name now and I'm so curious
what it is and it was making me think
like we haven't had a Kardashian new
name since Psalm which is really so long
ago and before I understood how
difficult it is to name a person so like
now my curiosity is off the charts I do
believe we will find out on this season
of this show yeah like I think that's I
don't think it's gonna be an Instagram
like I think we'll find out on the show
I
Instagram actually whenever she's ready
because she keeps saying like I think
still on his birth certificate it's wolf
right until she changes that and I don't
think she's changed it on the show so
she keeps just leaving it open but no I
loved her sharing all she was sharing
and it was a good reminder to just like
be kinder to yourself like we're making
human beings thank you [ __ ] hard and
there's no rush and to like enjoy like
appreciate the process you know
appreciate the process I definitely get
like a little Hasty and being like I
just you know I want to bounce back
immediately yeah but like whatever
whatever I totally agree you know like
there's a few moments where it's like I
wish I was like you know taking pictures
or whatever but like in the grand scheme
of things whatever no and it's like okay
so you have delicious I'm not saying you
do but like hypothetically like
delicious thighs uh yeah Harry came from
those thighs like you're getting these
loins yeah that's what I was trying to
say I'm not saying anything about your
thighs like I was just trying to make a
point
the subplot of Chloe taking the brain
test was giving e energy and it was
giving energy with a capital A you know
who's giving e energy Kendall she needs
to be oh another conversation she needs
to be stopped as Chris like everything
she says in her confessionals it's like
so Kardashians 10 years ago of like just
like fakeness no I she can do no wrong
for me like so genuine she's my Kylie
like I just feel like she's always like
delivering a lot sorry when she was
yelling at Corey to get in the car and
stop taking videos like nope that was
real time yes but when she's in her
fridge in her interview her fridge oh
her wine fridge in the garage with the
Crystal and the Dom and he's like which
one should I take like yeah he's so cute
yeah so Kylie so Kylie
um no I'm sorry there's nothing she
could do that literally I don't care
like she's your like I'm obsessed okay
good
um
yeah the brain stuff oh my god oh the
right doctor being like I've had Lakers
season tickets for 20 years it's like I
think people recognize that like these
are extremely famous people everyone
knows about Lamar no when he walked in
um and Chloe was like hi Kylie was like
hi this is my sister he's like hi Chloe
and she at the same time said hi I'm
Chloe like we know we know we know
you're no I love that for him yeah and
it's like it was like Tyler Henry like
where he was breaking the fourth
pretending to be like oh I don't know
what's going on here right even though
you know we know so I really appreciated
him and his honesty and his season
tickets we got like the p word she said
Pete and it was just like crazy and next
week is like all about people fight so I
think they took out anything too
emotional and serious yeah but are
leaving like fun fodder yeah and I also
think she said in the interview like if
in when Chloe was talking about Tristan
proposing Kim said if someone proposed
to me I would like have to say yes I
would like feel bad oh and that does
validate the theory that people thought
that the reason they broke up is because
P it invalidates it because then she
would have just said yes to Pete no no
no no no no no that was the reason why
they were saying that that was the
reason why they broke up I don't think
they would have left that sound bite in
that's true that's true I found that to
be quite interesting I also love to see
the girl he's traveling together to
Milan it made me want to go to Milan and
I've like never had any interest but
like the way they travel is just
fabulous like Kim air Range Rover why
were you saying a different Hotel I was
like just things that they do as sisters
but also as business women like it makes
no sense yeah they just have like
different teams and it's actually
shocking that they even flew together
right also Kendall is literally the
biggest model in the world for how many
years now and has walked in every single
show like and I'm so glad she like sees
Prada still as a big deal but why is she
acting like uh this was she was acting
great because she was acting like she
was acting when she was like 17 and
Chris went to the uh Victoria's Secret
like it was kind of rude first of all
like your sister's so proud of you like
there's an easier way to communicate
what you're trying to say I know what
she means like it's I think she already
has a hard time like backstage the girls
like thinks she's undeserving of her
career like the girls who literally like
lived in model apartments with 16 other
models like I get it um and it's like
embarrassing but like
it's not what she says it's how she says
it it gives off like such entitlement
and like it's kind of rude no but I also
meant like she was acting like oh my God
I don't know if I'm gonna get proud I'm
so excited I got like I guess it's good
that she's still enthusiastic about the
job but she was acting like this was her
first big break when like I imagine
she's walked for Prada before yeah it's
just another day I think that's her
attempt to seem grateful okay
which I appreciate it was
you know it was definitely weird and
like Kim was like so obviously like
excited to be in Milan like I think he
Kim spends a lot of her time like just
working on skims being a mom being at
home in Calabasas like when she gets out
without the kids like it's super fun
yeah and she's like genuinely excited
and I just think like Kendall's a little
bit more jaded yeah and I I love Kendall
representing the redheads yeah
um that felt really nice it was fabulous
and they were almost like really nice
throughout the hair color like Kim likes
it Kim likes red hair so I just felt
really that's good to know which is like
a general thing of fact of life yeah
there are some people who don't and then
Patty Stanger is like such is she
redhead phobic yeah wow she makes on her
show she used to make like the nastiest
comments about redheads
hate her isn't that crazy you would only
have remembered if you're a redhead of
course [ __ ] but she like would not work
with that no I guess you're right there
actually is like a small like group of
like bigots like let's say like fire
crotch and like ginger gingers have no
souls like yeah that are like Ginge
phobic
OTS I didn't think about that Patty
Stingers is the head of the committee
um and then Courtney we got like a brief
update on her fertility that like
they're gonna go the natural route like
at least one last time which is super
nice
um so then it also makes me think
because we're obviously months into the
future they got the embryo via IVF yeah
but I thought then they got the embryo
and so then they're gonna go natural and
then if it doesn't work then they have
an embryo oh okay so it just makes me
think like I don't know if she would
carry it so like any day now like
because this is months ago like we could
have a kravis baby yeah
God willing God willing God Willingham
Atlanta
uh and then so they bought their own
house in Palm Springs yes because that
was a Christmas mentioned that they were
doing that but it looks so similar it
was confusing at times all their houses
like have the same aesthetic like and I
think they're like down the street from
Chris's house that was nice so it was
cute
I could not be around people with such
PDA like that no me neither it's like
it's enough no I'm happy for them like
me too but it's like if you're the only
other person in the room it's a lot no
and like sharing just like with
people that like you did the dishes
naked is so unnecessary and then when
that person is your mom and her
boyfriend it takes it to another level
of unnecessary so unnecessary yeah it's
showing up like it's beyond unnecessary
there's it's just you know what it is
it's not necessary yeah one thing that
confuses me about the girlies is why
they always have their shoes on the bed
that's actually an amazing Point like
when Courtney and I'm sorry Chloe and
Kim were talking they were first like on
the corners of the bed with their like
Chloe was wearing her sneakers they were
off the bed and Kim's she was wearing
high heels yeah you're right didn't take
them off and then Chloe comes into the
crosses the bed to give Kim a hug on
Kim's bed and like her sneakers are on
the bed let me say one thing I do think
it's important to note that like the
[ __ ] on the bottom of my shoe is
definitely more dirty like because they
pretty much like go to their houses get
their cars lifted from places yeah like
they don't like they don't walk in the
streets they don't take public transit
no they're only in their own yards which
are plenty clean maybe they go to a
restaurant they walk four feet like no
they definitely there she was cleaner
than but it's a clean period but like
it's just shoes on the bed no I
completely agree and they're so clean
like Kim's house doesn't have a
tchotchke right but you'll have a shoe
on the bed I would love a clarification
on that that's an amazing amazing point
maybe they like put covers on their beds
that they take off at the end of the day
or maybe they're just so rich like they
get their sheets cleaned every day yeah
Garcon
perhaps that's what it is but it's an
amazing point I'd love some
clarification Kylie if you're watching
or hello yeah Kylie or Chloe we um I
just know that like everyone watches you
know yeah or maybe someone who like
works for them like can explain oh when
there's a shoe on the bed like this is
what we do or maybe it's a set it's not
their real house
is looking so good when Kim also like
acknowledged I don't I forgot what she
said but she was like
can we say that on Hulu
came in corindal Kendall take Milan yeah
yeah also I thought it was really sweet
how when they did Kylie's birthday used
the same song from I'm 34 weeks today
like her Vlog from baby number one it
was like the piano notesong is it Kanye
I didn't even notice yeah it's like done
done it's like a song with no words just
piano
so sweet so um 34 weeks today gotta get
pregnant just so I can say that yeah
that's a really good reason 100 the
Contour your Tick Tock yeah people would
love it
so um 34 weeks today
so it was a good episode honestly week
one was like crazy so this was more of
like kind of boring but those girls
these are just a pleasure to watch they
are they are the new show format is like
gorgeous I'm so glad we're over the
drones because season one I was getting
nauseous it's nice it's nice and I need
a Corey and Chris spin-off I need a
Corey docu series oh when Chris was
going through how she named all of her
children and literally forgot Robert and
then put him last and forgot his middle
name Queen
Queen and she has a [ __ ] stamp that was
fascinating fascinating eating
what a fascinating transition 100
percent
um so that was a TV recap
people were upset we didn't do a house
of the Dragon this week it was on
Jackie's it doesn't watch it yet she
also doesn't have DVR so you'll be back
home this week and we'll get back on
track on Monday yes that is our show
we'll be back
um next week shows Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday nope Yom Kippur oh my
God [ __ ]
oh my God the choice Brothers
[ __ ] I forgot Bruno it's okay mommy
loves you so Monday Tuesday Thursday
next week because Wednesday's Yom Kippur
and Friday I'm headed to Pittsburgh for
my show at the Roxanne theater tickets
available at girlzonejob.com tour good
luck getting one and I'm headed to
Atlanta for sports meet and greet at
Total Wine oh and mine's on Monday
October 3rd he asked me what day it was
I told him it was October 3rd
um in Long Island meet and greets so
we're getting like the entire Eastern
Seaboard cupboard yeah that's a little
bit up and down the coast all week come
see us thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning tell us the
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
Productions on YouTube please subscribe
give this video a thumbs up World's
available
have an amazing Friday and an amazing
weekend and we'll see you make it a
stride day guys make it a stride day